avec nous ce soir marcel groleau le
président de l'upe et à bon soir bonsoir
monsieur fillon
j'ai tardif à la fin mai et chaleur
accablante ensuite pas beaucoup depuis
au mois de mai est-ce qu'on est dans une
situation inédite et inquiétante
il n'est dit je ne sais pas inhabituel
on a eu aussi un printemps très hâtif
donc si on parle des arbres fruitiers
les vignes c'est à believe in you
bourgeonner taux étant donné la chaleur
qu'on avait dès le début avril est
arrivé les gelées comme vous l'avez
mentionné au mois de mai les jeux au
mois de mai ce n'est pas inhabituel ce
qui était inhabituel c'est tout le
bourgeonnement très tôt en 16 alors la
combinaison des deux a pas été très
heureuse
depuis le même en avril on a eu peu de
précipitation par rapport à un mois
normal et ans mais surtout en montérégie
les précipitations sont bien en deçà de
la normale même si au québec de façon
générale on a eu un mois de
précipitations qu'une année normale
c'est la montérégie est parti donc c'est
vraiment le sud du québec qui est
davantage affectée parce qu'on considère
comme une sécheresse à ce moment c'est
je dirais que oui depuis quelques
semaines on pose la question je
répondais toujours à temps dont il est
un peu tôt pour se prononcer mais
lorsque j'ai constaté les informations
que j'ai eues en montérégie dans
certaines dans certains secteurs on peut
parler de sécheresse
la végétation est arrêté les bassins les
rivières sont très basses et on prévoit
pas de précipitations importantes dans
les prochains jours simplement pour vous
donner une idée
habituellement au mois de mai en
montérégie on reçoit 107 mm de plus on
en a reçu 22 cette année
alors c'est sûr que c'est une situation
vraiment anormal ou plutôt est très rare
mais qui va causer des problèmes à
plusieurs producteurs alors qu'est le
problème c'est quoi des conséquences
bon d'abord des producteurs de céréales
comme les plans via bon vieux sommet
quand le sommet fin avril mois de mai
alors les plans sont jeunes
l'enracinement et pas très profond alors
lorsqu'il ment
d'eau pendant plusieurs jours le risque
c'est que ces plans l'oma ça c'est un
risque que les producteurs de céréales
en cours au niveau des producteurs de
fourrage on ne fait la première coupe on
a eu un rendement beaucoup moins là
c'est sûr que rien qui bouge en vue de
la deuxième coupe alors mais ça c'est
des choses qui peuvent se rattraper le
sida puis survient pour les producteurs
fruitiers
c'est ce que l'ours qui manque d'eau les
fruits sont plus petits la croissance se
fait mais les fruits vont demeurer plus
petit alors c'est ce que c'est des
impacts différents mais c'est des
impacts pour tout le secteur agricole et
le maïs et le soya qu'est ce qui se
passe mais c'est sur les plans sont
jeunes
on a su mais comme je le mentionnais
autres récemment alors lorsque il ya pas
de pluie la terre dure si sèche les
plans vont mourir tout simplement
alors parce qu'il n'ya aucune réserve
dans l'atlantique pour lui permettre de
traverser une canicule où une sécheresse
prolongée
est-ce que ça touche en grande partie
les maraîchers en ce moment et s concret
de manquer d'eau carrément dans les
prochains mois et ce sera bien pour les
paul custom area chez la plupart la
plupart d'eux et l'aigle leur production
alors mais ce qui risque d'arriver c'est
que les droits de plus et l'eau dans
certaines rivières vont être réduits
voire même quand c'est les lorsque les
rivières sont trop basses et les bassins
dans lesquels on a promis on entrepose
l'eau normalement on utilise pour
l'irrigation en mai et juin
c'est surtout pour juillet et à eau
alors si on vide les bassins en juin
déjà mais c'est sûr que ça laisse
présager le pire
au mois de juillet où là encore une fois
on compte sur la tap sur mer nature
équilibrer les choses mais ça on peut
pas faire grand chose vous et moi sur ce
qu'elle va décidément mais du point de
vue des conditions des travailleurs
est-ce que la chaleur accablante ralenti
en ce moment les processus de travail
dans les champs la frmse québec toujours
lorsqu'il fait très chaud mais on a eu
quand même une canicule de courte durée
deux jours demain on parle déjà d'un
refroidissement des températures allant
puis les des saisons la saison intensif
de récolter pas encore débuté oui dans
les fraises asperges c'est commencer
mais pour les autres légumes ne s'est
pas encore commencé peut-être aussi au
niveau de la salade mais donc on n'est
pas dans une période intensive de
l'école parfait on surveille ça de près
et avec beaucoup d'intérêt marcel
groleau merci beaucoup merci à vous au
roi pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit